- All right, Francesca.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Francesca, Where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Francesca] I'm from San Francisco,
California, North Beach.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents as a kid?
- I had both of my parents
but I've lived with my mother
and my father was around
but my mom and father weren't together.
- [Mark] How would you
describe your childhood?
- I had a good childhood, I really did.
I had fun as a kid growing up.
- No, no traumatic events,
no abuse?
- No, no.
[Mark] Nothing crazy went on.
- No, I know my mother, I
know she used to do drugs
but she kinda hid it very well.
- [Mark] Okay, and what time did you go,
you wanna turn off your phone maybe?
- Okay, well, okay, let's start it.
- There we go.
(Mark chuckles)
So what age were you when you left home?
- Say, what age?
- [Mark] Yeah, at what
age did you leave home?
- Like 16, 17 going on, yeah.
I mean, I still lived with my mother
but like I was out running the street
when I was like 16, you
know, I barely went home.
I had a boyfriend and I
started doing bad things.
Like I used to sell drugs and
a lot of other things, yeah.
- [Mark] At what age did drugs come
into the picture for you?
- Like, like 16 years old.
- [Mark] 16, and what
drugs we're using then?
- First I started off
smoking marijuana weed,
and then drinking, then ecstasy,
and then coke.
Coke led to crack cocaine.
- [Mark] And that's what you use today?
- Yes
- That's my drug of
choice is crack cocaine.
I also use black heroin.
There's different forms of using it.
I like to smoke it, I've shot it before
but it's not my thing.
I don't like needles
and I don't like to be,
I don't like downers.
I like uppers.
- [Mark] And where do you stay now?
You live in-
- I'm everywhere right now.
I'm practically homeless.
I mean, I've had it all
but I've lost it in the blink of an eye.
I have a son, he's gonna be
12 years old in a few days.
He actually lives with the father.
He's been living with the
father for the past year.
I've had three leases
before, and my third lease,
it was my dream, my
dream home you could say.
I had a boyfriend at the
time and I went to jail,
I haven't got in trouble in 13 years.
Somehow I got in trouble
in the wrong County at that
and I didn't wanna lose my place,
so I took the offer that
they were giving to me
which led me to get a strike
which I didn't know too
much information about
but that was the worst
thing I could've ever done,
any trouble I get like
any felonies or anything
like that can get me to go
to prison for a long time
with having a strike.
And I took it
because they said it's due
nine months with no strike
and three years probation
or 75 days with a strike
and three years probation.
I took the strike the
three years probation
only because I wanted to save my housing.
At that time, my boyfriend
had my ATM card to pay my rent
but he didn't pay the cell phone bill
which had me curious if, losing my place,
I didn't know whether, you
know, he does drugs too.
So people that do drugs,
they don't know how to function
and keep things on task.
But I was a functional addict.
I've always paid my rent,
I had no problem with that.
I had side hustles that would get me high.
And so I had no problem
with paying my rent.
I didn't wanna be homeless.
So I went to jail,
I had a boyfriend that didn't pay my rent,
I eventually got evicted,
I couldn't take care of my son,
He had to go with the father.
I'm kinda doing what I want right now.
I've been wasting a lot of
time, to be honest with you.
I'm not really on my job.
My job right now is to
actually find housing again.
I have an eviction on my record now
and it's gonna be a little difficulty,
but I don't wanna give up
because I always tell everybody,
never give up, and I go
by that, never give up,
keep on trying, because you will get it.
And so with that being said, yeah,
technically I'm homeless right now.
And my son is living with the father, so.
- [Mark] How do you
support yourself today?
- [Francesca] I receive
social security, ISSI,
and I receive food stamps,
and I date,
I do online dating,
I walk the streets,
and I pretty much use
my looks and what I have
- Yeah.
- To get by.
- [Mark] That can be a
dangerous lifestyle, right?
- It comes in hand in hand with the drugs
and if I wanna get high
which my drug is never
ending, constantly chase it.
I'm searching for that next hit.
I'm searching to get high.
I'm wanna stay high.
I do what I do, honestly, to get high,
that's the honest truth.
I've been there and done it.
I know what it is and I know what guys do
that 'cause the guys that
I've hung around with,
we get guys, I would
get girls, I mean, high.
And they know that they're
gonna want another one
because that drug,
once you take one you're
gonna want another one
and it's never gonna stop at that,
it just keeps going and going, going.
And I'm the type that I chase it.
My mother used to smoke crack cocaine,
I knew she was doing something,
when I was little she would
blow something in the closet.
But as I got older, I
became to do drugs with her
and we did crack together.
And she's a type that'll smoke,
but she'll put it out
at the end of that day
and she won't chase it.
And the next day she'll do it again.
I'm the type, once I hit it, I'm going on
for the next two, three
days until I fall out.
And so, yeah, my drug of
choice is crack cocaine.
I also do black Chiba.
I smoke it on a foil.
I smoke cigarettes and I smoke weed.
I know, quite a lotta habits
but my most number one drug
of choice is crack cocaine.
- [Mark] You've been arrested before?
- Yes, I have been arrested before.
- [Mark] What kinda stuff for?
- I got arrested for prostitution.
I've got arrested for drugs.
Pretty much, yeah, drugs,
prostitution, paraphernalia,
really that's, oh, robbery, robbery.
- [Mark] What do you think
most outsiders don't understand
about this lifestyle?
That'll drive to this neighborhood,
pretend to go in and
see these drug addicts
in the street.
- A lotta people look down
on us, you know what I'm saying?
'Cause I mean, there was a
time where I stopped drugs,
I was clean for seven years
and I would look down on people like me.
And I don't know why I did that
because you should never
look down on anybody
especially when you've
been there and done it
and you were in those shoes before.
And I hated that I'd done that.
I used to hate when people smoked weed
by my window or any of that.
So we get looked down a lot
on, down here in these streets.
A lot of people do think
that my lifestyle is easy and
that my job that I do is easy.
It's not, I might make it look good
but it's not for everybody.
And it's really hectic,
you know what I'm saying?
And it gets harder every day.
And I get low-balled every day,
it's the difference between
working the internet
and then walking the streets.
A lotta people, you know what I'm saying?
It's like value went down on pussy,
you know what I'm saying?
Like everybody thinks it's $20, $10,
and I don't believe on that,
especially me being a Caucasian female.
And I mean, look at me,
I really deserve all that and more
and I low ball myself
just so I can hurry up
and get the money and go,
but other than that,
this lifestyle is not something
you would wanna choose
or to be and it's not good.
And I know it's not good.
And I look too pretty good
to be out here on the street.
They'd be like, why are you out here?
But I don't really care what people think.
'Cause I gave up on what
people think about me.
I used to care what people think about me
before and used to hide
that I smoked crack
and I used to wait until
everybody was gone and smoke,
but now I spark on the street
anywhere on the street,
right before you came and got
me I was sparking up a hit
on my pipe, so it was just like,
it's just like that, I don't care anymore.
And that's the part I hate,
I wanna care, but I don't.
And that sucks.
- [Mark] What do you think
about your childhood?
Maybe it was the parents, maybe something-
- It has nothing to do with my parents.
It just has a lot to do
with the people I hung around with,
the crowd that I hung around with,
it had, I don't,
a lot of people do have a
reasons for smoking, and a lotta,
and the reason why I smoke
too is because I'm hurting.
I wasn't, I mean, I was in a bad breakup,
I'm still hurting from that, it hurts.
And so and my mother, my mom passed away.
So that's another reason.
And I lost my housing and everything, so,
you know, it hurts.
But other than that, a lotta times I smoke
'cause I liked the feeling
and I like to cover my pain
and I feel a lotta pain.
And so I just wanna smoke and numb my pain
'cause I don't wanna feel anything.
And I got to the point where
I got used to getting high
like this to where I'm
not happy without it.
I really ain't and I'm bored with myself.
Like, I don't know what to do with myself.
like I have all the time
in the world to think
about what I should do
but I honestly don't know what to do.
If I could keep my soul busy
and find a job or do
something with myself,
but it's to the point
where I need to have a drug
to get up now, like if
I don't have a drug,
I don't have energy.
I don't, I can't fully get up.
I just wanna lay in bed.
I can't even care for
myself, I can't even cook,
I can't, I can't do nothing.
It sucks to be dependent on a drug.
- [Mark] Have you had bad experiences
working the streets and
having guys pick you up
and stuff like that?
- Yeah, like sometime I
might meet the wrong guy
and like he might not be happy
with my service or something
and try to ask for the money
back or try to take it from me.
It's dangerous, the lifestyle I live,
I can meet the wrong
person in my life and just,
and you just never know.
And there's a lotta crazy guys out there,
and they're into tricking women
and playing games with them.
And so, sometime it's
good to have somebody
that's gonna be there
with you and guide you
if you were in that gang, and I'm the type
that I don't like to pay guys
and pimps and stuff like that.
I've never like paid
pimps, I had a boyfriend.
I mean, if you wanna call
it a boyfriend pimping,
but other than that, like,
I don't choose to pay pimps.
I don't believe in that, so yeah,
this lifestyle is kinda hectic.
- [Mark] You ever just stand back
and look at where your
life is today and go,
man, this is crazy?
- Yeah, it is crazy.
I wish I can go back in
time and change things.
And I just wish I never would have went
into that car that day
where I got in trouble
and I took the man's phone
and he didn't speak English.
I was wowed, the buses
stopped running in that area
at seven and I didn't have a car
and I just hopped into anybody's car,
the first three cars didn't
wanna give me a ride.
I asked politely I wasn't intending
to rob them or any of that,
'cause that time being I
was kind of walling out,
robbing people for their phones and stuff
so I can sell it and get
money for crack or whatever.
But at that time, I just really
simply just wanted a ride.
He didn't say yes or no and
the third car that I hopped in,
he didn't say, so I stayed in
the car, he was on his phone.
He picked up a client
and he's an Uber driver.
And the next thing you know we're driving,
I'm thinking he's gonna give me a ride.
'Cause he didn't say yes
or no, he didn't respond.
But actually in reality
he didn't speak English
and that's why he didn't spoke.
But I was led to believe
that, okay, I'ma get a ride,
but we're driving and he
got his client in the back
and we're driving in
the opposite direction.
So I'm believing in my
heart he's not taking me
where I want to go.
So I requested for him to stop the car
in the middle of the freeway,
because he's not going in
the direction I wanna go.
And I grabbed the wheel.
Boom, boom, boom, I
did a lotta bad things,
let's just put it like that.
And it caused me to put my hands on him.
I didn't punch him or
anything in his face.
I just shook him up.
And doing things like that
is dangerous, it's violent.
And then taking the phone,
that's, so it's robbery and fear
and being in San Mateo County,
they really don't play,
in San Francisco you can get
away with a lot of things.
So, I got in trouble and there you go.
So in a way getting in trouble
kinda got me to worry about
a lotta things I do now
'cause I can't afford
to get in any trouble.
And a lotta things that I do do
nowadays is a lotta bad things.
I shoplift, you know what I'm saying?
I do bad things and I'm
scared that I don't wanna go
to jail again, because any
felony can, if I get any felony,
I can go straight to
prison for like 32 months.
I've never been in prison,
I've been in County jail.
The most I ever did was six months.
And when I did the six months,
I went to jail twice on my boyfriend.
The second time he fell
in love with a woman
and it broke my heart and it sucks
'cause, you know, a
pretty girl, people like,
"Why you don't have a boyfriend or a man?"
And I just don't, and
a lotta guys out here,
they don't take relationships serious.
It's all about what you could do for them,
you would have to go to another country
and people value things over
there and value family, God,
and just all of that, over
here, nobody values nothing.
Everybody takes everything for granted,
You know what I'm saying,
'cause we get everything handed
to us over here, it is true.
Like we get free phones, we get this,
it's just like, it's like that over here.
And it sucks for the people that do work.
They work hard for their money
and they don't get as much as we do.
And it's like a lotta
people look down on us
and I don't blame 'em, but yeah, so.
- [Mark] How do you feel like,
this life, living on the
streets has changed you?
Did you become more suspicious or?
- It made me lower myself a lot.
like I should believe I'm worth more
but I've like, I feel like, wow,
what I've like done
things for certain money
for the price just dropped tremendously.
And it's like sucks because like, wow,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, I can't believe myself
for the drugs, and you know,
I dropped myself so low.
And so, and it's just not
good to live like this,
not knowing where you're gonna sleep.
So every day, like my hustle
and my thing is make money,
get a hotel.
I learned to not put
the drugs first anymore.
The drugs don't come first no more.
My hotel room comes first
'cause I need a place to stay
to do the drugs so I need a place.
So every day in the hotel I'm at,
they work with me like I can
pay some later, some now,
and I like that and they
let me bring a client
or two up there 'cause I spoke with them,
in order to pay that
rent I need their help
to, you know what I'm saying?
In order, I need to bring a
person to and they let me.
So my room is first, then the drugs.
So that's how it goes.
- [Mark] All right, Francesca,
well, thank you so much
for talking with me
and good luck getting off the crack and-
- Getting home, a house, housing, yes.
Thank you and God Bless.
- Thank you, darling.
- [Francesca] Yeah.